everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie today we're going to do some
things with graph Q up so if you've
never heard of graph QL before or maybe
you just haven't worked with it yet I'm
gonna do my best to explain things just
start out let me go through some of the
technology that we're using and then
that way if you want to go check it out
at least you'll have the names of
everything you can check out some
previous streams as well to see where we
set up some of these things but first of
all we're building a react website and
we're using Apollo to help us write the
you know graph QL queries to get the
data we're getting the data from a my
sequel database right through WordPress
right so it's just a normal WordPress
installation but we also have added a
plug-in called WP graph QL that's gonna
let us send queries to that plug-in and
then it's going to do its thing to get
the data that we need and then send it
back to our react app so what we need to
do today is write the correct query to
get the data that we need and be able to
display that data on the page so we've
done that once already for a different
page and Harshit who is frequently on
the channel frequent contributor really
talented coder has already set a lot of
this up for us so this isn't going to be
a from scratch video but we you will get
at least some of the basics of how graph
QL works all right I apologize for
scheduling this stream so late this was
busy with other things and then just it
kind of realized how late it was
thought oh
schedule this so I know there's probably
gonna be some of you who won't get to
see this live because you won't get the
notification to later so I apologize for
that I'll do my best to schedule earlier
tomorrow also sorry that I wasn't able
to stream yesterday it was there's
actually a water line break so the main
road to get to where I work is the big
hill
there's a water line break at some point
on the hill and water just went
everywhere all over the road down the
hill and it was so cold that it froze so
no one could go up or down the road and
so no one could get to work so that's
why I didn't stream yesterday those at
home and as many of you know my internet
connection just can't handle streaming
at home so anyway but I am in the office
today it's warmed up and I think it's
just slightly above freezing so roads
should be fine so let's get started and
if you have any questions just go ahead
and put them in a live chat and I'll
answer some questions a little bit later
on in the stream I'm gonna start a timer
here to remind me to check back in and
answer those questions and so I have
this is the data that we're going to try
to get so I've pulled over and we've
done this in previous streams if it's
shown how I'm migrating data from sequel
server database over into WordPress so
I've migrated these they're called
directories in the in the database so
they're directors they're basically just
listings of each department here at the
University I work at and who works there
with their title is what building
they're in and what their phone number
is so I'm hoping that they're all kind
of in the same order we'll find out when
we pull the data over but that's all we
just need to pull over you know this
piece of data is for the title and this
piece of data here and we're just going
to display that so I already have the
I'd set up and we'll show you that now
whoops I forgot to change the camera
apologies
here's what I was talking about we're
just gonna grab this data say it wasn't
really that important we're just gonna
grab the title and the content from
WordPress all right
so let me show you first of all the page
so we have a react component if you're
familiar with react this should should
look familiar to you
just pretty much a normal react
component we have some different things
going on since we're using next we have
this get initial props function
available and this helps us be able to
pull in data both on the server side and
client side so anything that we try to
grab inside of this function will also
that that data wall so B input into the
markup
that is built on the server for our
server-side rendering so that's pretty
awesome and that that's an XJS thing so
you won't find this in every react
project and so what we this is a copy
this was just a copy of one we've done
already for our posts jas so we're just
going to get the ID from our URL we're
gonna pass it and when the user goes
there and that's going to be the slug
that we need to be able to display to be
able to grab the right piece of data and
then we're just going to display that so
we have the title well we are we're
gonna have to add one tag just to
display the title but we'll wait till we
get some data in before we put that in
but we'll display the content here and
I've already changed this to be
directories so this is setup properly
the only thing that we're going to need
to change is we're not using this sample
query anymore we're going to create a
new
query and I'll probably end up changing
the name of this query when heart should
set it up it was an example so that's
why I was named sample query but I
changed it
you'll see here this query to be the
post J s so we ought to change the name
as well and actually our shits in the
stream right now so hey everybody I see
some activity on watch at harsh it let
me know and anybody else who who's
worked with graph QL let me know is it
the common practice to have a different
JavaScript file for each type of query
or is it a more common practice to have
multiple queries in the same file I
think in a previous project we had
multiple queries in the same file
oh hey Jason's here Jason is the creator
of WP graph kilo which is the plug-in on
the WordPress side of things that is
going to help us you get the data so
that's awesome well when when Jason's
here it's always a big help I appreciate
it
oscy so jason said in another meeting
but it fall along yeah that's cool
thanks thanks for joining us even though
you're busy with another meeting I
really appreciate it okay
someone away it's like I'm not getting
the response from hurshe maybe he's not
able to watch live let's see alright so
I really think I said I really kind of
think it's gonna get there's gonna be
way too many files if we try to put
everything in a different file right
okay harsh it's back arson I just wanted
to know if it was common practice to
have a different JavaScript file for
each query or to put the queries all in
one file or maybe hear them into several
files part of what says hey how's it
going all para I want to know which
library Apollo we're using Apollo for
our you know on the react side of things
so in any case basically it's going to
be very similar our query it's gonna be
let me double check but I think it's
going to be almost exactly the same
obviously we're not gonna get we're not
gonna say faculty we're gonna say
directories and we're not gonna say
faculty departments in fact I don't
think we have any categories at all
okay Harshit says that you can put you
can actually put the queries right in
the component if you're not going to
reuse them i I think I want to keep them
separate for now there's a chance that
we may reuse some of these I'm thinking
especially like this faculty query you
know we may want to pull that in we
talked last week about maybe having
highlighting some faculty members on the
homepage so we may want to pull in
something from our faculty pages and I'm
assuming you know we're gonna have some
other things like that so for now I'm
gonna make things everything a separate
component if we want to when we go to
refactor some of this if we find some
things that we're sure we are not going
to reuse we can always change it up
let's see okay Paula asks we using
Apollo server or Express graph QL let me
see Harshit set this up we think our
should I assume we're using Express
graph QL because we do have expressed at
least I was pretty sure we were running
Express yet did I see it no
are we not bringing anything in it right
now for that I guess not
all right so let's let's just make a
whole new file then and eventually we're
going to change this we will sort this
out as far as kind of the standard names
for our files in our queries but for now
let's just grab all of this let's make a
new file let's call this directories ojs
let's paste this in and what's let's
change our query name to directory query
we're going to change this to
directories and we don't need one two
three just counting out loud the number
of Semak or the number of curly brackets
I have and I don't think we needed that
at all let's see id title
slug content that looks looks like what
we need
all right great so let me save that
alright just an answer to par watts
question let's see how it says we are
using PHP WordPress graph QL server
provided by WP graph QL plug-in and
personally I recommend using Apollo
server I like more than Express graph QL
harsh it says install graph QL plug-in
just feels code would have a plug-in
syntax relatives queries oh all right
whoo I will I won't so that I'm not
gonna sell it right now during the video
unless you all think that would be good
to show let me know in the live chat if
you'd like to see me install a Visual
Studio code plug-in in the live stream
otherwise I'll wait and do it later
thanks for letting me know though
that'll be useful because we're gonna
end up writing a lot more of these
queries before this project is over all
right
let's go back to our directory dot j s
page component and let's change this to
director is is I what I said let's see
what I named it directory query
directory query
all right I want to set this up the same
way so we had before
wonderful all right let's see now I
think we have enough to test this yeah
so I already let me show you the server
I've already changed this before so I
added here in our server that when we
want to go to when a user goes to our
site's URL so be Franciscan dot edu
slash contact slash whatever's after
that second slash will get passed along
as the ID to our directory component so
the the route it's parameterised that's
going to say so parameterised routing so
you can check that out in the next
documentation so even though next comes
with its own router sometimes you still
want to do some things like this not
really hard to do
so I'm if you want to see the full thing
you check out the repo to check out the
repo for next as well there's a link to
this repository in the description below
alright so let's go here I do want to
make sure our slugs Counseling Center
since we have this one up let's try to
go to that one
so we'll go I think it's three thousand
yep so here's a site
and let's say here we go I must have
tried it before
so the reason directory query is not
defined alright that I'm not I must have
missed a step
let's check it out whoops I forgot to
import it that's I figured directory
query from directories so up here we're
importing a lot of the different things
that we need so if you didn't see I was
importing the wrong query so when I try
to call that query down here of course
it didn't find anything the reason I'm
using contact and not directories in the
URL is because the current site uses
contacts for for their URLs so I want to
keep the URL so you can see here we are
the data has come through and actually
the title did come through so there must
have been oh yeah it did have an h2
already in here so that's I was thinking
I'd have to make an h2 in the component
but it's already there that's wonderful
and the formatting actually is not
really that bad I think I can live with
that formatting really I mean obviously
we want well you know we're gonna want
some padding and things like that but
just in general not really too bad for
that formatting I mean really if
anything it might not be a bad idea to
have it stacked so that it's you know
named title and then building and phone
number although since they've added this
in is this this pipe here does make it
difficult
but not bad all right so let me let me
test out a few more just to see if we
have consistent in the consistency with
all with our data I've checked a few but
I haven't checked everything so let's go
in here and see let me check out my
department let's see what the slug is
all right now about a little bit
different so for some reason we have a
lot of space in here and we have a phone
number at the top but so not bad but the
format of everything you know here is
the same and there I am
don't call me during the stream that
will just feed the stress but all right
not bad
we just have to keep in mind it's kind
of double-check these to fix the spacing
and things let me try one more as I
think we may have some departments that
are a little irregular
remember see if I can remember which one
was a little bit different
I see let's let's go through the say
oops type the wrong thing in let's check
out the live version of the site right
now Franciscan dot edu slash contacts
let's see general contact info
admissions let me just open up several
there we go admissions was the one that
was that was different
let's see if wow this is interested
missions had a completely different URL
as well maybe that didn't even come
through see there's little things like
this that are making this somewhat
difficult no admissions wasn't even part
of this so yeah what I I guess we'll
just have to be aware of this and try to
figure out you know what to do
I'd love to keep as many of the URLs
intact as I can but some of the
structures not really I don't it doesn't
make a ton of sense right so I I do get
that this page is supposed to be for
prospective students so they wanted to
make it different maybe more attractive
for students a little different layout
but the whole change in URL makes it I
don't know it just makes it problematic
I guess for trying to organize
everything so there may be some cases
where we might want to display the same
content on two different pages because
you know I think it would make more
sense to have admissions underneath that
section of you know contact right but it
it may also make sense to have the
admissions counselors listed in the
admissions section right also you can
see who's not listed here there's some
people maybe I just have to go to the
next page but there are definitely some
people in the department who are not
listed here at all so for now we'll just
go on to the next one alright this look
standard
department chairs all right that looks
pretty standard I want to know if that
actually came in contact up into my
shoes great that did come in good
contact directories I had this one I'm
not sure what this one is why was that
even in there
Wow so development departments link is a
link to a different site this is a bit
of a mess let's I about three minutes
left on this this Pomodoro cycle and
then we'll go to the live chat but I
think this is gonna be some change to
how we do this because from a user
experience standpoint I don't think this
is the best if you're trying to go
through and get contact info for this
depart these departments you know
there's a certain standard layout for
some departments whether you go to
admissions and it's different it doesn't
even show all the employees you go to
development and it takes you to the site
where you have go to give money to the
university it doesn't even list the
people that work in development so we're
gonna have you're gonna be different I
think we're gonna maybe like have to
either we'll do it you know I'll do it
or we'll get someone else to do it put
in in WordPress you know some extra
directories that follow the standard
pattern to make up for those sections
that we're seeing here that that just
link off to unexpected places even some
of the office of Khattak addicts doesn't
even have a link Community Relations I
mean I realize they do have a phone
number but
you know what we'll have to see because
this is definitely you know a bit
confusing and we may have to to make a
page like this so the page that is just
contact will have to be may I don't
think it all came in I thought it was
this one yeah this does not look like
it's the same as this page is it general
contact info let me double check maybe
it was yeah maybe it is okay so we do
have this that's good
alright so we maybe will just have to
work out the URL then that's good news
at least we have something to go on all
right I'm gonna go to the live chat now
I know we have a minute left but I mean
what am I really gonna get done in a
minute so let me start this short break
timer and I'm gonna check out what's
going on in the live chat
so I got a little distracted I got a
message from my wife I just she's asking
me a coding question my wife's learning
how to code she's doing the Flatiron
school right now
Mikey says something about spaghetti not
sure not sure what you're referring to
Mikey may have to clarify
okay par what mentions saying a polo
server is is not stable okay I'll keep
that in mind thank you
Nura asks why are you not in Facebook
live I've never done Facebook live is
there a reason why I should be on
Facebook live as far as I know free code
camp doesn't do live things on Facebook
so we have a presence on YouTube I'm
pretty sure there was a twitch channel
as well but I don't think we do anything
with that right now
Paul watt says hey Jessie who set up
this project
Harshit did a lot of the setup so I mean
I did the initial setup of you know next
right and I created like some of the
layout but then in terms of all the
graph QL stuff Harshit set all that up
so pretty much everything in this lib
folder har should set up a little bit
everything I've done in here has just
been slight modifications you know based
on our needs with the data so it's been
a collaboration if you want to know
really who did what
check out the repo and look at the the
commits
let's see
all right so harsh it said the name of
the visual studio code plugin for graph
QL is is in his blogs if you've never
been to harsh its blog very helpful and
informative it's HP tech blogs comm so
check that out there's a lot of good
good blog posts in there about you know
react and different technologies for
really like full stack development Paul
watt says hello everyone I have a github
repo of graph QL real ajs implemented
you can check it out my username and
github is par 108 so that's P a RW 8008
thanks for what I appreciate that maybe
I'll check that out see depending on how
long the stream goes maybe I can check
out out after I do have to leave work a
bit early today so I may not have time
but I will check that out JC Q says hi
from Malaysia hey how's it going thanks
for watching
netskope says I always have trouble
making navigation bars got any tips from
me
it depends on what you're using so if or
if you want to let make it from scratch
you know with just CSS HTML then I don't
it just really depends on what style you
want to make I would look at I usually
copy and paste code from previous
projects or check out how its
implemented in other projects but if
you're using some sort of framework if
it is just a regular HTML site you know
check out bootstrap or materialise or
foundation or one of those and it'll
help you a lot with the navigation
borås if you're using react you can
check out you know material UI or uh
there's a react bootstrap there's you
know there's a lot of different options
but you you could probably find a
component library or a single component
that would do a lot of the work for you
so I mean you definitely have some
options there and then once you get
through it you know once you have some
code to go with you know you can always
copy and paste and adapt it you know for
for future projects so anyway that's my
advice if you want a more specific
advice and you have like a particular
project you're working on now you know
let me know send me a link to it or
something to the code I I could check it
out and help out so but just in general
you know I'd say you know don't try to
do it all from scratch if you don't have
to you know definitely use some of those
the resources that are available all
right and there's a few more questions
my timer went off but I'm just going to
go through these last few questions that
are on here this is I'm so close to the
bottom the hopeless Brit s opinions on
learning PHP versus learning JavaScript
with node do you think we'll see PHP
dropping off or do you think it will
always be an item in it depends on what
you want to do I think if you want to be
well it if you want to be a front-end
developer you must learn JavaScript
JavaScript is everywhere no matter
what's used in the backend if you want
to do backend stuff though you don't
have to go a node right PHP is still a
valid option a lot of things use PHP
it's not going anywhere anytime soon
just WordPress alone the existence of
WordPress and how popular it is I think
guarantees PHP is going to be around for
a while because WordPress runs on PHP
and if you want to specialize in that
then definitely learn PHP but what I'm
doing
and I I kind of recommend this unless
for some reason you you know really like
another back-end language is just go
full stack JavaScript you know we don't
have all the time in the world right
people are busy you only have a certain
amount of time to dedicate to learning
so why not learn one language and be
able to do front-end back-end right it's
a lot easier so I mean that's the way I
look at it so I'm focusing solely on
JavaScript both front and back-end
I do way more with the front-end but as
you can see on these streams we still
have to do some things with servers and
form handling sending emails and things
like that so we do work in the backend a
bit but I think either one is still a
valid option for back-end programming
PHP or node I do see I don't know
numbers but I get the feeling that using
node on the backend is getting more
popular I don't know if PHP is
necessarily dropping off but I I don't
get the feeling that is it is you know
gaining more traction so that's just my
feeling though from you know social
media and articles and things I don't
have any numbers on that so don't don't
take that as for sure hopefully that
answers your question
Victor says being new to programming
should I learn to program JavaScript
before languages like Python alright so
this kind of fits a little bit with the
last question and I would say it all
depends on what you want to do if you
want to get into more stuff with the web
JavaScript for sure if you're not sure
what you want to do and maybe you're
interested in I don't know like game
development or data science or like
machine learning I think Python is a
great choice I don't know that much in
Python but the little bit that I have
you know done with it
I enjoyed using Python the other option
to consider is
if there's a certain company you want to
work for or a certain type of program
you want to do you may want to do some
research into what's used right if if
you if the company you want to work for
only uses Python no sense learning
JavaScript right or it could be they
could be using something else you know
completely so once you weren't learn one
language it is a lot easier to learn the
second one so don't feel like you'll
always be stuck with with that one it's
you know programming is programming it's
dropping from one language to another is
mostly just learning new syntax
all right netskope says yeah use
bootstrap already so this was the
question from earlier about navigation
bars so netskope says I use bootstrap
usually but sometimes you have a project
at school we're not allowed to use this
stuff and just need HTML CSS this is
where I usually get stuck okay all right
good that's a little bit more specific I
would say this check out what's going on
behind the scenes in bootstrap so look
at one of your bootstrap projects where
you have a navigation bar that looks
kind of like how you want it to look on
your your plain CSS project and go in
dev tools inspect things and see what's
the actual CSS behind those class names
and then maybe you'll get an idea for
for how it's done right you can take
that then adapt it to what you need and
I think that's a good way to see how
they do it you can even try you know
check out some other sites and see how
they do it
you know you'll find differences there's
there's not just one way to to do it you
know even the positioning of all the
links and things there are several
different ways in CSS that that could be
done sometimes depending on what the
menu does you know there may be
JavaScript in use so that's what I would
do just do some some dev tools
inspecting and that should give you a
give you an idea of of how different
things are done
all right
there's
all right let me a hardship is really
excited about me installing this plug-in
so let me install it really quick so
command P and what are we gonna do and
paste all right let's
all right let's check it out that
actually was really fast our shoot
you were right where's our I think I
have anything open in terms of
directories oh here we are
okay cool now we have some nice syntax
highlighting with our queries awesome
thanks argit
that was super easy all right let's see
alright well we actually we we did what
I wanted to do and we finished it in one
Pomodoro session so I mean I I thought
it it was possible that we could do it
but I we just did it really fast so I
guess I'm gonna go through the live chat
a bit if there's anything that anybody
wants to see me actually do I in this
project let me know otherwise I'm just
going to do some live chat stuff this
may end up being a short stream and
unless I can think of something that
would fit you know kind of with what
we're doing but so we have a comment
here from Basel and it says hello
it says guys hello from Ukraine hey
how's it going
is it basil or basil how is it how is it
pronounced let me know I want to make
sure I pronounce it properly for you the
hopeless bridge says I think it's always
good to learn it without a framework
first move on to learning frameworks for
CSS and navigation stuff hopeless bread
also says node is growing here in the UK
and cheers for the response oh no
problem
hope hopefully it was helpful netskope
says is it normal that I want to learn
everything like web development app
development game development etc yeah
you know what I think that's normal
especially if you're starting out
something you said earlier you were in
school so yeah I think that's that's
normal you're not really gonna know what
you want until I think you start to
specialize and even then there's always
going to be a part of you that says wow
it would be cool to work with this so I
mean I still do that I've been doing web
development I don't know I've been a
front-end developer here for two and a
half years and then before that I was
freelance for a few years and I there's
still times when I read about you know
some other new tech technology and I'm
like wow that's really cool I want to
get into that
so but I'm happy with what I do you know
you can't learn everything and you can't
expect certainly can't be an expert at
at more than you know one or two things
at once unless you know maybe you're
you're some type of one-in-a-million
genius or something like that
but even then someone who's a genius
could always be better at one thing than
at multiple things at once right that's
that's what specialization does
specialization is great because you get
better at one thing but saying yes to
that one thing means you're saying no to
all the other things is you only have so
many hours in the day but anyway at that
point at this point though netskope
I'd say try out a little bit of
everything and figure out what you
really like and then go into that and
then you could always switch later on so
you know don't feel like you got a I'm
not saying you do feel like this but in
case it happens don't feel like you you
know you're gonna get trapped in one you
know one area the horseshit says my
first language was Java by the way oh
cool haven't really done that much with
Java for a long time once did a little
game in Java though it was fun
hopeless Britt says Java is great never
really supported the fact that our uni
made us learn both Java and then C++
yeah when I the the one computer for a
main course I took in college was C++
made it calculators
Mohan says hello from India looks like
I'm a bit late to the party you know
what I got finished with what I wanted
to do so much earlier than I normally do
mainly because everything worked
North normally I messed something up and
it takes a lot longer but everything
worked this time so I'm happy that it
worked but I guess it makes the live
stream a little bit
boring
let's see the hopeless Britt says what
do you often find more challenging /
rewarding front-end back-end or
full-stack I definitely for me at this
point I think back-end is more
challenging I've been doing front-end
for longer and it's it's so visual I
think it's really easy to see when you
haven't got it right and when you got it
you know you can just look and see
alright that looks great or you can tell
immediately that won't work that's
terrible it looks awful back-end is not
like that as much you know they're so
coming from the front end and now trying
to learn back end of course back end is
is more challenging to me front end
seems more rewarding though simply
because you see your result at the end
of the day and other people see it like
I never have compliment somebody saying
like oh you know you the back end on
that app is just amazing no nobody says
that they always say all the sites so
beautiful it's so clean it's fast so the
back end may have something to do with
all that but people don't see it
now if personally rewarding I do really
like when I get something to work in in
the backend because it's hard for me so
it is rewarding in that sense I would
love to be full-stack at some point I
think it would be fun and provide you
know for a lot of variety I'd also be
able to you know complete you know
create things you know completely on my
own if possible I really do like working
with other people especially with with
you all on projects but if I really
wanted to I could create a project on my
own so I'm moving towards that direction
I mean I think for those of you who
watch the the stream you know for a
while now I think you probably have seen
more of a progression of you know us
getting into more backend things so I've
definitely come a long way you know just
you know in the last year with that but
you know for now I'm front
is my thing actually that reminds me
I talked with I was talking with
somebody yesterday about learning
management systems and they were talking
about how there's just not a lot of good
options out there especially for open
source learning management systems and I
know we've talked about it before on the
stream but I think I really want to
start working on a learning management
system built with react full-stack
JavaScript like progressive web app
style right I may be there's something
like that out there but I don't know
about it yet I just think that would be
very useful especially for you know
companies just starting out they don't
have a ton of money to be able to commit
to one of like the big learning
management systems I don't know I think
it would be cool make something that's
really fast can work offline you know
just think how much like in countries
that don't have reliable internet access
like how nice would it be to be able to
have a progressive web app as your
learning management system so that like
a non-profit could just use this
open-source system you know in a lot of
those places so you know people have
cell phones you can just load it you
know as a web page right and you know we
could even do a you know an app with it
if we wanted but loaded as a web page
you know load up a lot of the stuff you
need for the class so that when you
don't have a connection it's right there
you can do your tests and everything
when you do get a connection everything
just gets synced up oh yeah that would
be really useful if someone knows or
something like that that's already out
there you know let me know I'd be happy
to check it out or maybe even help
contribute but if there's nothing like
that right now I think that would be a
really cool thing to work on so if
anybody else thinks that would be cool
to work on you know let me know I'm you
know I'm busy I mean I think we're all
kind of busy but that that's something
important that I think it would be cool
to make time for and could really help
you know help out a lot of people so
anyway
you know I would need probably I mean
obviously like front-end design stuff I
got that a lot of the react things you
know I have that but this would be
something where you know you would need
it connected with a database and I'm I'm
not great with databases you know we
would need some type of login system
user authentication we definitely want
it to be secure right there's gonna be
student records and things so there's
going to be a lot of areas where I'm
just not gonna have the knowledge and
it's probably not the best use of my
time to try to get better in those areas
if that's not really my thing right now
if I have to I have to but if anybody
out there knows more about that and
wants to help you know let me know I
think it'd be a cool project so maybe
I'll make a repo for it soon you know
just so that we could
you'll get started get some ideas start
talking about it alright I'm going to go
back to the I'm gonna go back to the
live chat now and answer some more your
your questions Lucas says good afternoon
my friend good afternoon thanks for
watching rook says what does the with
rude higher-order component actually do
something with styles let's see with
root component where we get
where am I missing that was that what it
was called
there are my components there we go yeah
so let's check this component out we're
bringing in our styles go with your
background all right yes so this is
wrapping our our mui themed provider is
from obviously material UI so this is
wrapping everything you know within our
app in there and then yeah we got a lot
of other stuff going on with our styles
which I'm not even sure I'm assuming
this is a lot of the stuff I think are
she did this I'm assuming this is a lot
of the setup from the material UI Doc's
on how to bring in on how to bring this
stuff in but basically yet what it's
doing is just making sure that all the
material UI theme stuff is available in
our components
ours it says as project is getting to
completion what is your deployment plan
will you be using digitalocean site now
is getting really good you can scale to
multiple servers on one command with
managing servers I you know what would
have to think more about that but I I
don't think I'm gonna go with
digitalocean
I think maybe AWS so Amazon Web Services
or I'm open to something like using
using site I've I've done some side
projects on site and I do really like it
it's really easy so I'm gonna have to
reassess yeah it's been a couple months
since I first came up with a deployment
plan we actually even before that I
started planning it out you know a year
ago so maybe I should reassess before I
really have to launch and see you know
is the plan that I came up with before
still the best way to do it maybe not
maybe there's better a way to do it now
that you know that I either didn't know
about or didn't exist before so I'm glad
you brought that up it would definitely
be helpful to be able to scale things up
with a command instead of managing
multiple servers so that's a really good
point hard [ __ ] yeah whatever we do we
just have to make sure it has all the
functionality that we that we need which
really I mean we don't even have contact
forms on the site right now so it's
actually gonna be pretty basic so I just
want it to be fast whatever we do it
just needs to be fast and reliable
see the hopeless bridge says great job
with that sequel and PHP very true you
never hear that I don't remember what I
said the hopeless Brit I don't remember
what I said that that comment is is
directed toward let's see hopeless
spirit said I have to say I think
projects like Khan Academy gave me my
inspiration to move towards the full
stack developer side of things cool you
know what I actually haven't looked at
Khan Academy for years
I'm gonna have to check that out and see
what they have available on the site
even for my own kids I think maybe it'd
be useful all right in regard to this
component this with route Harshit says
it server renders material UI stylesheet
and classes using JSS okay and then
reuses the context on the client all
right that makes a lot more sense as I
was looking at this I kept thinking this
is a lot more setup than we've used
before with the theory you I and that
totally makes sense now so to be able to
use material you I with our server-side
rendering and on the client side then
that's where a lot of this stuff had had
to happen so thanks for clarifying that
hard [ __ ] dragster says I have a
question can I use react without node J
s I guess I believe you can I have never
done it but right correct me if I'm
wrong but you can it you can use react
without node right because you can use
reacts client-side right okay he's
saying right I don't want to say
anything wrong so let me know if I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure you
use react without note and if I you can
use it just client-side if you want to
I should also says you don't need to
manage the SSL's if you use it-- that's
cool I'm not really worried about the
SSL it's kind of you know once you set
it up and set up the Auto renew it's
it's not that hard you know it's only it
you know less than an hour set up but
that is cool that it manages it although
that might be an issue I know because
the IT department purchased some SSL
with all this insurance or something for
the main site and they may want us to
try to use those certs I I don't know
we'll see how that goes all right
hopeless bridge says Khan Academy is
such an amazing platform plus you can
find a lot of their learning tools are
open source very cool I'm definitely
have to check that out
hopeless bridge said they for sure gave
the site a facelift could be a lot
faster though yeah I really think a good
learning management system should be
fast right that the slowness of the
system could definitely distract the
learner right so I mean speed is speed
is important for every site but I think
it's very important for that I mean
there's already someone who's trying to
learn something already has to fight
distraction so much to be able to focus
you know you don't want to cause them
more distraction by either having a
terrible UI or having your site be
really slow so I think yeah like the it
you know if you design it right off the
bat with that in mind I think you could
definitely have something that's really
that runs really quickly
it's not hard sang Zeit automatically
uses HTTP - very cool
it says the katha catechol site has a
good speed and it's not using HTTP -
yeah the katha catechol site is fast I
mean way faster than some of the other
university sites that were made before I
started working here all right cool
Arsen says you can use custom shirts was
i all right that's cool I'm not worried
about it
I don't I think we'd be fine with you
know let's encrypt free certification or
you know SSL certs but I don't know
we'll see I mean you know how things are
sometimes you know if if that cert was
already purchased for I don't know years
in advance that's not gonna look good
for the IT department if you know
anybody higher up found out like oh you
paid all this money for the search
you're not even using them you know you
did it for free so you know just to like
kind of help them out it might be better
just to use them and then maybe when
they expire switch over or something but
I don't know what the case is all have
to talk to them and see exactly what's
going on trying to think too if they
have it I mean they may have it be
applied to other like subdomains - I'm
not sure what what's going on with that
I wasn't involved that much in the pro
mean I encourage them to get is an SSL
certificate but I wasn't that much
involved in actually you know purchasing
it and you know applying it it was I
don't really know that much about iis
servers anyway so that wasn't my thing
Harshit says you should enable HTTP to
HTTPS ooh and nginx settings and
catechetical site all right that's cool
I'll definitely have to look that up I
hadn't even thought of it but I should
do that yeah I I do as you all know I
mentioned I do want to make some updates
to the cata catechol site I've been
working on it we updated a bunch of
packages on the stream but I need to
switch over the videos not working
anymore now that I updated so I'm gonna
switch that up to YouTube instead of JW
player and try to get it to work like
that and I need to make some other
changes to the UI we're gonna add some
contact forms and things so there's
definitely more work that needs to be
done and in that process of doing all
that I think that would be a great time
to update some more things including
using HTTP to update packages on the
server you know a lot a lot of things
like that
Harshit says but if they purchased did
you sort use that it has what is that a
million insurance or something I don't
know how many zeros are there
yeah million yeah like I've said yeah if
they already purchased it then I'll use
the they're purchased certificate but I
would like to know like how much time is
left on it if they only have a few
months before it expires then do we
really need that we're not taking
anybody's payment information we're not
even having a user login or anything
like that I do we really need the
insurance I don't know off to look into
it the hopeless Brit asks so if you've
got any experience with laravel I think
if I ever was to learn PHP framework it
would be larva I personally have no
experience with laravel but I I hear
about it I see articles about it things
so I think that's probably a good way to
go if you do want to do PHP you know
larvell seems like the way to go but I
don't really I don't know that much
about it I just know that I see it
mentioned a lot all right whoa
I think been streaming for about an hour
so decent length stream anyway I got
through all the live chat now so which
end up being a really good chat I love
it a lot of great questions got some
great info as well so I really
appreciate all that I think I'm gonna
wrap things up so I should be back
tomorrow I'm gonna try to do things
stream over around 1 p.m.
I think that's seems to be a good time
for a lot of you you know that are
watching from different time zones yeah
so anyway thanks for watching today and
until tomorrow have a great day